last night I told you how the president
exposed the Democrats true shut down
motives namely the Democrats love the
partial government shutdown because they
think it helps them politically which is
why they refused to move even an inch on
the issue of wall funding well today the
president exposed the media's motives in
this drama as well now rather than
giving us in-depth objective reporting
on the effects of illegal immigration on
average Americans all of you out there
on your jobs on your school's on your
safety and on your health the media
spending their airtime parroting
Democrat attacks on the president's
character and motives his whole frame
around this entire debate the entire
shutdown the entire government is shut
down of our scam this is not a border
security crisis that merits a wall it's
a humanitarian crisis where the
president was incredibly disingenuous
because he said that the shutdown that
is the shutdown is because Democrats
will not fund border security that's
just false now before the president
speech last night the media vowed to do
their inste fact-checking well they
wanted to do this in real time President
Trump
preparing his primetime speech as the
fact checkers prepare for their version
of the Super Bowl the primetime pitch
from the president that is expected to
send fact-checkers into overdrive
tonight we're all gonna be doing
fact-checking you know here at CNN they
have been really throwing a lot a lot of
dodgy and false statistics around what
do you what do you expect to see yeah
we'll be fact-checking relentlessly
Chris well the fact check Squad didn't
fare too well I would have rather had
the Mod Squad frankly in the aftermath
of the oval office address the media
collapsed away from kind of the fact ret
its fact checks into old tropes and well
some awkward admissions one in three
women are sexually assaulted some way on
the journey I don't know about that
stuff
I can't weigh in every day Customs and
Border Patrol
agents encounter thousands of illegal
immigrants trying to enter our country
okay so here's the fact the fact is
while border apprehensions were up in
October and November that's not unusual
he was delivering the speech it was so
low energy that if Donald Trump were
running against that guy he would call
him Low Energy Don he was the first-ever
presidential address by a collapse
souffle when he looked defeated deflated
terribly if I was that crowd I wouldn't
talk about looking terrible all right
well first of all first of all what
happened to the fact-check it's good
luck well you said thousands of people
come in they just devolved into well he
looked tired well their latest tactic
and we're gonna see more of it in the
coming days is to repeat your the sob
stories of government workers who still
by the way have not missed a paycheck
well
watch carefully about what they're doing
here rank emotional manipulation pure
propaganda now how many of these
segments did they do over the years on
American workers who pushed out in or
pushed out of entire industries as
unscrupulous employers hire them for
cash or at a fraction of the salary how
many close-up interviews of victims of
legal alien crime did they do you know
then by the way those people aren't
experiencing a temporary loss of income
but a permanent loss of a family member
look at the front page of today's New
York Times
which sought to frame the president's
address this way well see the photo it's
a photo of migrants you can see it there
it's getting smaller but migrants at a
Tijuana temporary kind of migrant
shelter now once again the media
focusing on that interviewing people at
the shelter putting the feelings and the
concerns of non-citizens
over those of actual citizens well at
least they have that nice wide screen
and they could enjoy it on that but
perhaps the voters after watching all
this hearing all of it are not so easily
manipulated a morning console poll found
that a
reality of Americans 42% believe this
situation at the border is a crisis
including 72% of Republicans obviously
far fewer Democrats now Trump has
successfully shown that the Democrats
are not substantively engaged in problem
solving on this issue of the border but
still the media continues to carry the
water for them but when reporters begin
acting like pundits Kellyanne Conway
showed us yesterday exactly how they
should be treated can you promise that
the president will tell the truth
tonight
will he tell the truth yesterday man can
you promise that you will the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God am I allowed to mention God to
you you know Jim I know that's a to make
sure that goes viral this is why by the
way this is why I'm one of the only
people around here moving gives you the
time of day let me just let me get back
in your face because you're such as most
of the time and I know you want this to
go viral a lot of these people don't
like you
but let me just be respectful to the
media writ large as I always have I
explained that that was alternative
information additional facts and I
explained it many times and don't you
put it back in my face for all the
corrections that your network news issue
by the way she said smart ass ok it was
all over television yesterday it's
better to just lay it she obviously has
been learning though from her boss a
little bit all right here's the Trump
Smackdown of ABC's Jonathan Karl that
happened today in the Oval Office as the
president was actually doing the
business of the country a series of
human trafficking bills were signed
let's watch why not sign the other bills
though so some of these workers can get
paid the government think I should do
that you know do you think I should do
that John I mean it's not for me and I
watch your one-sided reporting do you
think I should do that John no seriously
John do you think I should just side
well do the are dinner tell me tell me
do you think I should just die I'm
saying that if you sign that these
workers can start getting paid the
government said you would do that if you
were in my position you'd do that I'm
not in your position you should never be
in this position because you'd never get
anything done
goodbye everybody thank you very much I
was devastated by the way the the bills
that were actually signed human
trafficking which all these other
administration's we're gonna do
something about Trump is actually doing
something about it while all the other
stuff is going on around him and women's
empowerment Democrats are supposed to be
all for that funding for all sorts of
women entrepreneurship programs Ivanka
Trump's been working on that knows that
was signed into law as well didn't
matter not gonna cover it but we got to
play the pundit game with the president
Trump is dominating rhetorically and
substantively tomorrow he heads to the
border where he's going to again I
predict take control of the news cycle
today he actually went to Capitol Hill
and he met with congressional leaders at
the at the White House before that again
the Democrats were not interested though
in solutions only in the sound bites
afterward well unfortunately the
president just got up and walked out he
just walked down again we saw a temper
tantrum because he couldn't get his way
and he just walked out of the meeting
okay no the president decided that he
had had enough the Democrats the
Democrats just aren't operating in good
faith here so the president walked out
refusing to be part of their shutdown
soap opera he wants to get to yes they
want to stay at no of all the media
outlets out there though the AP was one
of the few to properly frame the
situation in a tweet they wrote
Democrats put the blame for the shutdown
on Trump but it takes two to tango
Trump's demand for 5.7 billion dollars
for his border wall is one reason for
the budget impasse the Democrats refused
to approve the money is another well
guess what the AP was lashed by liberals
for doing that that little tweet just
look at the online reaction looks like
my Twitter feed AP fact check
Hindenburg was a very fine blimp and
Democrats failed to appreciate it
because it takes two to tango ap
fact-check authorities put the blame for
Hannibal Lecter's murder spree on the
serial killer himself but it takes two
to tango
amazing well Trump continues to be a
powerful political astringent as I like
to say and the face of politics as usual
is feeling the sting especially the ones
we saw last night
well it ain't pretty
the real collusion my friends is in
Washington and it's the one that Trump
has so masterfully exposed it's the
collusion between the American media and
the open borders Democrat party and
that's the angle